hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll back in 1747 julien a freud
elementary wrote an influential book
called man a machine this is I think in
the Enlightenment period in Europe one
of the first works to come out strongly
in favor of being an atheist there were
hints by various people that maybe God
wasn't all he was cracked up to be
but still this was absolutely clear man
a machine that God didn't exist we human
beings are more like machines than
embodied spirits the 18th century was a
big time for machines in France and the
rest of Europe so this is a vivid
metaphor at the time and elemetary was
not one of the world's great
philosophers but he was more like a
pundit I guess we would say in these
days he had very vivid metaphors and
language and examples
he put his case in a very clear way for
people to understand I remember one of
the points that he made I'm paraphrasing
now it's been years since I read it but
basically he was arguing against Rene
Descartes s-- idea of mind-body dualism
that a human being is a body but then
there's also a mind that it's
disembodied and somehow they talked to
each other and that makes the person
such elementary didn't buy this he
basically would say that the human being
is a physical object and the mind is
emergent in our modern language but the
example he used was he says look when I
have had my cup of coffee or not had my
cup of coffee I'm a different person
depending on whether that's happened or
not how can you possibly believe that
the mind is completely separate from the
body when it's perfectly clear that my
mind is deeply affected by what happens
to my body it's a very good point really
went and of course the people who don't
believe him have answers to it etc but
nevertheless the example lingers in your
mind these days when we know even more
about how the brain works how the body
works how the mind works but still don't
know nearly enough we're advancing in
the direction of understanding not just
how the mind works but how to change how
the mind works by messing with it by
giving it coffee or giving it other
sorts of substances so today I'm talking
to Robin Carhartt Harris
who is head of the Center for
psychedelic research in the division of
brain sciences at Imperial College
London Robyn is one of the first people
maybe the first people to study the
effects of LSD and other psychedelic
drugs on patients in controlled clinical
trials I should say he and his
collaborators right it's medicine
there's a lot of people working on this
but for years now following the dictates
of the United Nations of all people most
countries have just held all research
into psychedelics off limits and those
rules are finally beginning to soften a
little bit so we can do things like give
a patient some LSD or some psilocybe and
put them in an MRI machine and see
what's happening to their brain we're
learning a lot we're learning about both
how the brain works for its own purposes
we're curious about that but we're also
learning about how there might be
therapeutic advantages to using drugs
like this there was a certain reputation
that psychedelics got in the 60s in the
70s and that gave them a bad image as
far as public relations is concerned but
there's enormous potential here for
using these for treating depression for
treating addiction for end-of-life care
for pain management or just for helping
people sort of become at peace with
themselves in different ways it's very
early days I think for the research here
we really don't know that's why it's so
fascinating to start thinking about it
so remember the podcast mindscape has a
webpage preposterous universe calm slash
mindscape where you can get not just the
show notes for this links to people's
webpages and their research publications
or what have you but also full
transcripts of all the episodes there
are links you can click on if you want
to donate or things like that people who
donate and become patreon members don't
get ads on their podcasts and they also
get monthly ask me anything episodes and
with that let's go
[Music]
welven Carhartt harris welcome to
mindscape podcast thank you nice to be
here so there's a lot to discover here
about psychedelics and therapies in the
brain and things like that but this is a
topic unlike some that I do where I'm
presuming that many of the listeners
either have experience or opinions at
least they know what LSD and magic
mushrooms and things like that are so
but but there's a history that I think
is fascinating why don't you say a few
words about the history about you know
how these things came to be and also the
legal choices that made it difficult to
study them over the years yeah sure I
guess the history comes in a few phases
people have talked about waves you know
you have the first wave of psychedelic
plant medicine use which is ancient and
you know major geographical areas in in
Central America and South America where
psychedelic plant medicines have been
used for you know countless generations
and know a lot about how deep that goes
back and the history of those things in
South America some people do it's not I
have no particular expertise but it goes
back to with mushrooms I think it's fair
to say thousands of years in Central
America okay in terms of mushroom
related artifacts I mean it could be
something else but they look pretty
mushroom art and pictures as well that
go back a long way to depict mushroom
ingestion ayahuasca it's difficult to
know and because perhaps a lack of
artifacts but at least you know several
hundred years back and very much
ingrained in certain cultures in Peru
and Brazil yeah and then with an LSD for
example we discovered in 20th century
right yes Albert Hofmann who was kind of
commissioned by drugs company Sandoz to
play around with some ergot derivative
that was his expertise our gots a fungus
that grows on certain grasses ripe grass
and was associated with you know some
interesting vascular effects and also
some intoxication as well poisoning and
so he was looking at the potential
vascular effects of the drugs
potentially related to stemming bleeding
in in birth okay and so it wasn't
looking for menthol no it wasn't so it
was a classic you know medical
serendipity that led him to and when was
this
this is 1938 he was playing around with
the the drugs the war happened things
got shelves and it was 43 when he now
famously took was it 200 or 250
micrograms which he thought was a tiny
amount of LSD turns out that's a pretty
big drip and then the now celebrated
bicycle day the first bicycle day
happened then in April I think the 19th
1943 he took that dose of LSD and was
shocked at the effects thought he was
dying
actually before he got there he jumped
on his bike and rapidly cycled home
because he somewhere comfortable he was
well he was on on his way out but it was
he describes what sounds like a quite a
nightmarish experience his neighbor
comes around and she turns into a
malevolent witch who he thinks poisoned
him and yeah he thinks he's dying and
yeah so that's the second wave and now
we're in this Renaissance period the so
called third wave and in between we have
the 1960s good time in some sense and
but I guess a sad time in another sense
in terms of the pushback against
psychedelic Dru
which had very significant implications
for psychedelic drug research and
medical use leading to essentially a an
outright ban on any kind of work with
psychedelics from the late 60s onwards
and it's been decades really of hiatus
in research until I guess in the 90s
most significantly have characters like
Rick Strassman and Franz Valen Vidor
doing pioneering work to bring
psychedelic compounds back into the
scientific space and then and then the
naughty hiss you know with significant
things happening at Johns Hopkins I
guess we come onto the scene in the UK
in the late naughties around 2009 mm-hmm
I started brain imaging research with
psilocybin and we find ourselves here
today where you know this is starting
really to become quite mainstream and it
was banned internationally in the 60s
right there was some like the United
Nations but they don't have much legal
authority but they did at least
recommend that countries not let you use
psychedelics for therapeutic purposes is
that yeah it was the UN wide initiative
so any countries that fell firmly under
that were implicated and that's most
Western countries in the Eastern Bloc
actually they carried on for a little
bit longer doing work in the Czech
Republic and a certain stanislav grof
he's you know such a key figure in in
psychedelic work he carried on doing
research with LSD
into the early 70s but then that dried
up as well and was it is it true that
part of that was actually a backlash
literally against hippies using LSD in
protest yeah there's a few conspiracy
theories but I don't think you have to
be too inventive in your imagination to
see how these things fit together and it
was a time of particular social and
political conflict in the u.s. very
polarized and it seems there was a fear
that perhaps psychedelics were fueling
some of the counter cultural sentiments
yeah and probably just a few things were
going on in terms of certain politicians
seeing that it can be a potent you know
vote winner to be seen as being hard on
drugs yeah exactly and I guess Nixon
sort of embodied that with this war on
drugs and before that I don't know with
LBJ it was him really he he started to
you know curtail things and there maybe
it was Vietnam and a fear of people not
being so loyal and obedient and has
having a bit of an anti-authoritarian
spirit and that being tied up with the
whole psychedelic and drug use thing
okay but now we're sitting here in your
office at Imperial College in London
where you do research on these
substances presumably it's legal do they
change the law or did you get an
exception yeah it's an exception you get
a license from the home office and it's
not trivial to get one and they're quite
expensive and that's a shame because it
pampers science
hampers collaboration it's not easy just
to send some drug off to another team or
take it over to them and you know they
need to be recognized and listed with a
home office and if they're setting up
they have to set aside a few thousand
pounds too and a bit of building work
you need a bridge this lock bolted to
the wall and there are inspections in
such liking these things might seem kind
of trivial but you have to be really
motivated to make them happen right and
it's quite easy you know with all the
relevant pressures that you have in any
domain but in academia
to just not bother ya know and and say
it's hard enough for me to get a grant
to do theoretical cosmology much less
you know get get a drug you know
visiting sense to the lab that's a whole
other thing well grant winnings been so
difficult I think there's only being
warned I mean the Medical Research
Council in the UK supported our
depression work and that's kind of an
exception NIH are in the UK have
supported a colleague of mine said that
was a year ago so so things might be
changing but I I know not much has
happened in in the US with ni MH and you
know you have some obvious absent ease
there in terms of major funding bodies
that haven't supported this and that's
got to change soon I want to pause for a
second to talk about policy genius.com
if you're like me buying insurance is
something that you know is really
necessary but you don't look forward to
it it's a mess there are a lot of
different choices out there you're not
sure which policy to buy etc policy
genius.com
makes all that very easy it makes
getting the right life insurance or home
insurance auto insurance disability
insurance all that stuff will be a
breeze one thing it does is it compares
insurance policies from different
insurers so you can see exactly how much
things cost what gets covered and you
can choose what will be best for you and
then the people at policy genius will
handle all of the paperwork and the red
tape so you don't have to spend your
valuable time worrying about that stuff
so as 2020 begins you can check
something off your to-do list if you
haven't quite gotten this done yet
go to policy genius get life insurance
it takes just a few minutes to find your
best price and apply at policy
genius.com
policy genius will always get the future
wrong so why not get life insurance
right so let's explain to people what
actually happens when a person takes
some of these psychedelics for one thing
is it fair just to use the catch-all
phrase psychedelics or do we need
really distinguish between the different
ones we could take yeah I think we need
to distinguish it's a very sort of broad
brushed as this extended definition of
psychedelic which I guess in a sense
exploits the the word itself the
etymology their psychedelic means mind
manifesting our mind revealing and so
people might say oh when you smoke
cannabis you can have these major
psychological insights and when you take
MDMA you can have insights and some self
realization so under you know that
definition will will extend the
definition of psychedelics into the
include these compounds another way of
but so but sorry but technically most
people who do psychedelic research would
not include marijuana for example I
wouldn't because you know I guess it's
the science thing where you know you
need to be crisp in your definitions and
and so for me the best scientific
definition is one that that comes from
the pharmacology which is classic
psychedelics and some examples there
would be LSD arguably the prototypical
psychedelic because it was only after
its discovery that the term came along
mescaline as well given that Humphry
Osmond came up with the word in he was a
Canadian well his British psychiatrist
working in Canada he became friends with
Aldous Huxley oh yeah a brave new world
and the doors of perception right which
was his essay on his mescaline
experience okay and the mescaline was
provided by Humphry Osmond and so from
that there was you know a realization
shared realization that we needed a new
term for this category of drugs Osman
came up with psychedelic and but yeah so
mescaline played a role in the birth of
that term as well a key role so LSD as a
as a trip to me and
tryptamines compounds that's molecular
Li are very similar to serotonin five
hydroxy trips me and another one is
dimethyltryptamine DMT which is found
endogenously and some very small amounts
in humans and many other animals we
think and lots of plant species DMT is
the major psychedelic ingredient in
ayahuasca this Amazonian brew so there's
some examples but the the crisp
definition is that all of these classic
psychedelics share a certain
pharmacological property which is that
they stimulate a certain serotonin
receptor the serotonin 2a receptor and
then I could say a lot of I think
interesting things about the 2a receptor
where it is in the brain what its
associated
I think you should say those interesting
things yeah where is it in the brain so
what is that I mean this is a
neuroreceptor in individual neurons yeah
yeah it's it's in the membrane of
individual neurons and the first thing
to say is that the receptor is heavily
expressed in the cortex that aspect of
brain that humans have so much of all
the wrinkly stuff you know massively
expanded in our species and that's where
you find these these key receptors that
psychedelics work on so we're gonna be
more susceptible to psychedelics than
cats and dogs probably they seem
sensitive too but they don't you know
their behavioral repertoire you know so
they just twitch and that kind of thing
that's our behavioral index of whether
dogs and rodents are tripping or not
yeah in humans we have lots of cortex we
have lots of - a serotonin - A's the
receptor and it's not entirely evenly
distributed in the cortex the cortex
like so much of the brain and so much
the body and nature is hierarchical
a hierarchical organization and at the
top of the hierarchy have the
Association cortex which in a sense is
the most mysterious because it doesn't
have an obvious modular function like
the visual system for example you know
which most of the visual systems in the
back of the brain it's clear what that
does yeah and the motor systems for
moved movement motor action but the
Association cortex is sort of like a lot
of a lot of things and and associated
with Association and high-level
psychological functions like imagination
so stitching things together and coming
up with yeah scenarios yeah
yeah stitching things together imagining
things that aren't there immediately in
the environment so that's referred to as
counterfactual thinking mm-hmm
something that people say might be
unique to our species mm-hmm another
thing that people say is probably unique
to our species at least in the magnitude
that we have is self-consciousness right
probably what sets us apart and that's
where you know that's a function
associated with the Association cortex
where you see so much of these 2a
receptors so that's a good starting
point
you know the receptors in an aspect of
the brain that evolutionarily is quite
recent and massively you know expanded
in our species and associated with these
high-level functions then we could look
at what happens when you stimulate that
receptor to brain function and there
I've introduced a notion which I hope is
useful this entropic brain idea oh okay
we're entropy were big fans of the word
entropy here in the house game parties
and this is where in a sense I'm
stretching my expertise because it's not
in physics but or an information theory
but I know that in information theory
entropy is quite a fundamental metric
related to our uncertainty about a
system where if entropy is high
uncertainty
hi we don't know what that systems gonna
do next it's unpredictable
and they're the principal with
psychedelics is quite simple this
entropic brain principle which is that
psychedelics increase the
unpredictability of spontaneous brain
activity
okay so rather than spontaneous just
means ongoing rather than a vocht by
like a stimulus of some sort right so
that even when we're trying to be quiet
and stealing our minds there's a lot
going on yeah spontaneous brain activity
okay
and you can think of you know stream of
consciousness and imagination
daydreaming those kind of things going
on yeah and the stuff that he trying to
get a control over in mindfulness
exercise or at least yeah you try and
still with focus there's a few kind of
interesting paradoxes there but
ordinarily you know that quality of
consciousness is pretty rich but under
psychedelics we found it's richer still
and we found that there's this
interesting really quite reliable
relationship between the richness of
ongoing consciousness if you want and
ongoing brain activity well I mean maybe
before we get there is there what is the
role of serotonin in the cortex other
than psychedelics is it naturally
appears and yeah what it's there for
with serotonin is really complex in your
own modulator so it chews neural
function rather than it being a simple
excitation or inhibition thing it's more
about a complex tuning and the
complexity of serotonin is reflected in
its a number of sub receptors there are
at least 14 have been identified and
they all do quite different things some
of them actually oppose each other's
function another thing that you see in
nature and the 2a receptor is excitatory
and it seems to increase irregular form
of excitation
there might be a clue as to what we see
at the population level so groups of
neurons where we see this entropic
effect where the activity becomes harder
to predict more complex right in the
presence of the serotonin or in the
presence of psychedelics so well it
there's in terms of the basal the
functioning of the serotonin 2a receptor
this the suggestion is that it doesn't
do that much because if you give a
blocker of the 2a receptor it doesn't
really do much to consciousness okay
it might make you a little bit sedated
might make your thinking a little bit
narrowed and stereotyped but it's a
subtle effect cognitive rigidity but
it's quite subtle so that's the low
entropy high predictability yeah kind of
phase yeah yeah and it might be
associated I guess by implication with a
narrowing of the range of conscious
contents and say to a blockers in
medicine antipsychotics often have a to
a blocking component and some sleep
trucks as well to a blockade seems to
promote deep sleep okay so it's kind of
the opposite of what you see with
psychedelics but it but then there is
this rule of it doesn't the blockers
don't seem to do that much they
certainly don't you know it's not the
dramatic impact on consciousness that
you see when you stimulate that receptor
which is what the psychedelics yeah and
so part of the part of my thinking and
and I think others around the to a
receptor is that maybe it becomes
engaged naturally during exceptional
conditions if it's not really doing much
Basel II so you know in a kind of
ongoing background kind of way then
maybe it's there for some kind of
emergency situations perhaps crises and
I've got a paper in development at the
moment which proposes that hypothesis
and I've written other things that have
sort of led up to that hypothesis that
it's a kind of
crisis button in a way you know
activating the to a system serotonin to
a system so in conditions of somebody
else's said existential distress crises
maybe you need to induce these very
plastic brain and mind states hmm be
more flexible yeah because your life
literally depends on it or you know your
I guess well-being very much depends on
it like something has to give something
needs to change you having some kind of
psychological breakdown
whatever complex reasons your you enter
this state of hyper plasticity and and
then beyond that maybe life is is never
the same again okay you can think of
examples like epiphanies religious
epiphanies hitting rock bottom and major
transformative experiences they happen
you know outside of the context of
psychedelics so it's natural to ask why
do they happen how do they happen maybe
they happen in a related way to how
psychedelics work okay and so when we
take the psychedelics and so know we are
grouping all the psychedelics together
in this conversation should we should we
be more careful about yeah asking which
one does what yeah when I talk about
psychedelics I'm really talking about
the classic psychedelics and there I
think it's probably most useful for
listeners to think of the examples LSD
psilocybin which is found in magic
mushrooms DMT which is found in lots of
plants and in ayahuasca mescaline is of
Fernet limine isn't this like different
class but it's still a classic
psychedelic okay so all these stimulate
these this particular serotonin receptor
yeah and so I guess I'm quite get clear
how I should think about what this is
doing to the brain so there's a lot of
things going on in our brain even when
we're trying to be quiet or our eyes are
closed or whatever and my impression is
that the psychedelics rather than excite
the brain they sort of let
the bringing have some access to what's
going on anyway in some sense is that
fair yeah it is fair it is an excitation
but it's a it's an irregular form of
excitation so perhaps rather than think
of it in a quantitative way you know
where people have historically they talk
about regions in the brain lighting up
or metabolism increasing or decreasing a
little bit like something like a
thermostat or something you know going
hotter or colder it's a little bit of
these days a bit of too crude a way to
depict the brain where it might be
better to think of the quality of brain
activity changing okay and the thing to
say is that the regularity of brain
activity changes activity becomes
dysregulated that's right I do remember
reading about you know the network
effects in the brain become a little bit
less predictable I guess yeah yeah and
does that have an easy relationship to
the classic things that we think of is
happening when we're on an LSD trip in
terms of hallucinations visual and
auditory or even I mean sometimes people
see things that that are just not there
many times people just see things that
are they're moving in weird ways right
yeah yeah so that notion that
psychedelics are hallucinogens a little
bit misleading with eyes open things
distort yeah
and sure things can sort of emerge if
you're looking at something like the
clouds or whatever or you're on DMT and
then things are really wild visually but
it's more when you close your eyes that
the experience becomes very rich in
imagery and very very vivid as if one is
seeing with their eyes closed
mm-hmm it like dreaming is it a bit like
dreaming or is it really the same thing
as dreaming in something it's probably a
hybrid yeah it's not this it's not quite
the same thing but I've speculated and
others have and there's bits of indirect
evidence to back this up that the
tripping state if you want is a hybrid
waking dream States and so part of the
mechanics and physiology of dreaming is
actually happening while you're awake
under a psychedelic and there you know
in the set and this actually is probably
the reason that drew me into this whole
area in the first place in the same way
that Sigmund Freud famously said of
dreams that they were a royal road to a
knowledge of the unconscious mind others
have said the same Stan Grof and others
about psychedelics and then you put two
and two together anything ah by you know
a matter of kind of converging evidence
there's something to this unconscious
mind business yeah one of the reasons I
started mindscape was because I had too
many books to read and by having the
authors of these books as podcast guests
I would force myself to do it for those
of you who don't have podcasts of your
own you might want to try the bling
kissed app bling cast is a wonderful way
to get a glimpse into what a book is
saying without going through the whole
thing without having to read the entire
book basically in 15 minutes of reading
you can get an essence for what the book
is actually about some of my books are
on blinka stand also other books by
previous mindscape guests there are
books by Carlo Rovelli Adam Rutherford
and others so with plinkus do you get
unlimited access to read to listen to a
massive library of condensed nonfiction
books all the books you want in for one
low price right now for a limited time
blinka Staz a special offer just for
mindscape listeners go to blink east
comm slash mind scape to try it free for
seven days and save 25% off your new
subscription that's blinka spelled BL i
NK IST blink is calm / - cape to start
your 7 day free trial and you'll also
save 25% off but only when you sign up
at plinkus comm / mindscape
probably a lot of people who are not
professional neuroscientist or
psychologists have a a pretty overly
simplistic direct view of how the brain
works like there's a visual feel that
comes in and we have a camera in our
brains and there it is right and we hear
things and that's also going on at the
same time but my impression from my
rather amateurish readings and these
things it's it's way more complicated
and there's a lot of processing going on
in the brain just to give us this this
image of the world that we see around us
right like the what we think we're
seeing is highly processed compared to
what our eyes and visual cortex actually
picks up absolutely I mean you could say
it's highly constructed in a kind of
top-down way as in there's a lot that
we're experiencing that comes from the
brain itself rather than from the
outside world and this is what you know
Kyle Kristen will say hopefully in a in
a very elegant and thoughtful and
precise way perhaps in a way that's
difficult to understand but no there's
this notion the Bayesian brain based on
principles of probability that we house
in our brains internal models through
which we experience the world and so
much of experience is the product in a
sense of these models that we house
rather than some kind of receptivity of
information coming in right and and the
action of psychedelics is a bit of a
clue to that being true in the sense
that we can almost see these models that
we've constructed even the really
high-level ones like our sense of self
and that's probably the most profound
realization that people have on
psychedelics is all my goodness you know
my my sense of personality is an
absolute
you know and all the you know spiritual
related sort of follow follows on things
that follow on from from that experience
yes come into play yeah so we should
think of what is happening to our brains
on psychedelics you know not as seeing
new things but as you're you seem to be
implying that we're revealing things
that are going on inside our brain
already yeah it's almost like an outside
observer you can look at sort of in a
sense how the brain and mind work and
these it's probably achieved through the
fact that these internal models break
down mm-hmm
recently I've written with Carl on this
topic a review paper that we've entitled
rebus for relaxed beliefs under
psychedelics bit of a fudge fit so that
looks at Ness but but it's hopefully
it's memorable and yeah the idea is that
the what's called precision weighting or
confidence that we have in our internal
models so like our confidence in who we
are mmm dissolves breaks down relaxes
and psychedelics and when that happens
there is this you know curious
possibility to step outside of the model
and then almost sort of view it or view
its realize its absence and almost have
a third-person perspective on our verses
and try sona's lots of interesting
philosophical questions like then who is
the observer right but well I talked to
Daniel Dennett recently on the podcast
and so you know he is one of the
originators of this multiple drafts
version image of consciousness was a lot
going on that are sort of suggested ways
of viewing the world in your brain and
then this I guess this associative part
of your cortex knits them together to
make some final draft but
yeah so if you know one of them is the
final story I guess and if you if you
get to look at them individually you
realize how nonunitary are ourselves
really are yeah yeah how the narratives
been stitched together yeah yeah
multiple drafts yeah
and is this you know a lot of people
have advocated the use of psychedelics
for unleashing creativity in some ways
does this speak to that do you agree
that this is a good kind of thing to do
yeah probably the you know the biggest
block to creativity is being too sure
mmm being too confident
too low entropy yeah yeah and you know
which is it's a it's a curious one and
you can think of other drugs that work
perhaps even in a sort of polar opposite
way to psychedelics that give confidence
you know the stimulants maybe a drug
like cocaine mm-hmm
we've actually published some work that
based on a on a scale of ego dissolution
and ego inflation these two drugs go in
different directories
yeah so it makes you a little bit more
sure of yourself yes it inflates the ego
yes you may be less creative possibly
yeah yeah might be very productive right
exactly you might come up with a lord of
stereotypes you know manic kind of
ramblings that aren't particularly rangy
and expansive whereas with psychedelics
you really get that expansion whether
you can get the focus it's another
matter
I mean there's the classic example of
being on psychedelics and thinking that
you've had a wonderful insight and you
try to write something down and the next
day it's just nonsense right yeah yeah
there's then yeah the quality control
comes in the BS detector the editor
comes in Pat's afterwards but you know
perhaps not always so fiercely and
there's a lot to be said and people are
increasingly aware of the
that's the integration process the
landing process after a big psychedelic
experiences is so important and there if
there isn't too much haste to try and
stitch things back up but rather just
let them slowly kind of settle and
crystallize in a way that's most natural
without forcing any kind of I don't know
psychoanalytic interpretations
necessarily and it's probably in that
that way of treating it as a sort of
organic process that things settle most
healthily and sometimes there's there's
a there needs to be a principle of just
sitting still with some uncertainty
perhaps things aren't so crystal clear
now and perhaps things aren't so crystal
clear full stop and say you know that
often comes up actually in our
therapeutic work with psychedelics where
a patient might want closure on
something you know something as literal
as was i abused you know when and
there's a responsibility i think on our
part not to force such a closure and
there are historic examples of where
that's gone wrong in in traditional
psychotherapy right you want an answer
yeah yeah and sometimes it's just hard
to get or not they're not you know I
don't have evidence to decide one way or
the other yeah so there is this also
this feeling that informally forgetting
about scientific research but people
feel that they are getting some deep
insight into themselves or into the
nature of existence or something like
that when they're on psychedelics I've
always wondered how much of that is you
actually have gotten an insight or you
have gotten the impression that you've
gotten an insight somehow I mean are
there things that really stay with
people afterward you know once they're
no longer on the drugs that are counters
profound insights about themselves there
are but that I mean that's you're really
hitting on the million-dollar question
and again you know the answer isn't
isn't to black and white sometimes
people do you have
profound insights that stick with them
that changed their lives that they can
communicate to other people who hear
them and the message lands and resonates
and they say wow you know and when that
happens often it's it feels like a deep
spiritual wisdom and so the resonance
really is with things that one could
read about and say Buddhism or spiritual
texts and they're it's these are
insights that of course aren't specific
to psychedelics at all they're just more
they're more fundamental and basic than
anything to do with psychedelics it's
just it so happened that for some people
psychedelics have been the tool that
have really led to whatever
breakthroughs that people have had and
for some you know spiritual teachers I
guess gurus if you want you know some
quite well-known ones psychedelics have
actually been especially Western ones
psychedelics have been you know the the
door that's open for them that later on
you know what they've done with with
that drug induced in scientists who put
it into spiritual practice right and
they're I think the key term is is
practice you know rather than just keep
going back to the drug where after a
certain period of time maybe you know
there's more noise to be experienced
than signal they've thought instead
there's something to do there's some
action to follow that that's a healthier
way of okay of being rather than going
back to you know the drug teacher and
all the projections that I can go with
that that's you know there's something
inherent to the drug that holds this
intelligence I know I think that can
that could be quite a dangerous and
proper
Masek well it's very interesting what he
said about the sort of loosening versus
tightening of your thought processes
when you're on a psychedelic versus a
stimulant there there's this
long-standing informal belief that
madness and creativity are somehow
connected to each other right
being creative involves looking outside
the box thinking of new things but in
some sense you can the box is also
important right like you know the the
ordinary rules also matter and it's all
about finding a balance between them and
our psychedelics a way of sort of moving
the balance in one direction or another
and then going back and forth and is
that useful yeah it can be useful and
but equally it can be potentially
problematic I mean it can be useful when
the the constraints of the box are too
firm and and it's it's holding up
progress and perhaps even leading to
pathology whether personal or on a kind
of systemic level like on a social level
people do have bad trips right and is
that decide depend on the person more
well they do have bad trips and
sometimes they are really bad I mean
there is this sort of fashion I suppose
in the psychedelic science community to
say there's no such thing as a bad trip
it's challenging experiences they call
them challenging you know they're things
to work through and overcome and there's
a lot of truth in that but equally for
the sake of sort of plain talking some
trips are really really awful so yeah we
can call them bad they're not
fundamentally bad intrinsically in and
of themselves but they close themselves
very unpleasant yeah hellish and and so
you know I guess as a scientist there's
some deep fascination in those
experiences and to try and understand
them I would lean towards notions of the
collective unconscious you know Carl
Jung and and archetypes you know around
sort of demons and devils and monsters
you know very ingrained human images and
ideas that are
yeah so you're saying that when people
have a bad trip they we can help
understand try to understand what
they're going through by reference to
those ideas absolutely ok is the best
way to understand a problematic way to
try and understand them would be to say
that they're literally real or no to
invoke notions of magic that perhaps
some bad demons are in as bad spirits
are in the space or whatever right kind
of projecting things into some
metaphysical space I think is hard you
know one of the kind of subtle sometimes
perhaps not so subtle pitfalls of
psychedelic drug use well that's you
know sometimes I get the impression that
people who are advocates for this really
think that they're not just discovering
something new about their brains or
their selves but about the nature of
reality and I'm very skeptical about
that I made sure that the nature of
reality is being revealed here no
although they might they might have some
insights about the nature of nature
possibly but then you also have these
there's a lot of pseudoscience that
comes into this space a lot of magical
notions and a lot of contradiction that
you hear as well people talk about all
the Western approach and the scientific
analytical approach and how it's so
reductionist and then they'll bring up
some you know loose idea around the
vagus nerve that's responsible for
Kundalini you know and it's just a
really vague and and and horribly
reductionist as well yeah so there are
some annoying contradictions but ok
speaking of the Western scientific
method you know here you're doing
experiments why don't why don't you
describe an actual experiment you would
do on a patient by you know giving them
some psychedelic and looking at their
brain somehow yeah
ok I mean we have been doing some
interesting work with DMT injecting it
into people and then
recording to volunteers I presume yes
healthy volunteers and then recording
their brain activity with EEG you know
there's caps that record the oscillatory
activity in the brain look a little bit
like swimming caps no it's a sensors on
and then fMRI as well and recently we've
completed a simultaneous EGF MRI study
okay one of my PhD students Chris
Timmerman has been leading that work and
so that's quite pioneering and and it
allows us to bring together the high
temporal resolution of EEG with the high
spatial resolution of fMRI look at
things like complex patterns in the
temporal activity look actually
literally at its complexity at its
entropy but also look at brain networks
and their dynamics and their some
principles are emerging out of that and
then it's really as good science perhaps
or just science does it throws up
interesting new questions and future
studies to think about so with some way
through in fact the plan is to begin
this in the next month in February to
begin a protocol of actually begin the
the the experiments themselves following
a continuous infusion protocol with DMT
so typically we've we give a bolus of
DMT and it Rockets people into this DMT
space where you know they feel so
profoundly immersed in this other world
that feels as real as this one but is
you know 60 very very quickly yeah yeah
and is content-rich visually incredibly
rich
you know that kind of avatar type scene
is probably pretty easy yeah
from ayahuasca and DMT visions but it's
that kind of thing and and people often
report encountering entities seemingly
sentient other beings in this DMT world
so which is not what he was he from LSD
no not really no it doesn't quite reach
that intensity LSD I think you mentioned
is more like the things that you do see
are altered right yeah in certain or if
it is or shoe things yeah and that can
be sort of it perhaps richer kind of
deeper notions and memories personal
material and trans person material can
emerge under LSD over a longer timeframe
and say therapeutically those
longer-lasting psychedelics okay like
LSD and psilocybin or all psilocybin
yeah they're different in that sense
there's more therapeutic gain to be had
whereas it DMT IV or smoked DMT is more
like this short sharp blast into this
other very weird hyper real space so it
held for two short what's the typical
draws less than twenty minutes minutes
okay any button you're meeting other
sentient beings yes and people come back
and they're whole you know which you and
I like to think are made up in people's
brains not know it's what an exciting
opportunity for studying the archetypes
yeah I think and yeah and you know the
dynamic fabric I suppose of the
unconscious mind that that was what
lured me into this space it was that
very thing really when I first got into
this area and yeah so that's obviously a
huge challenge but that's the that's the
opportunity so just so I mean some
people not gonna be experts here these
are not thought to be addictive drugs
that you're given eyeball right so when
you get volunteers there's we're pretty
sure that they're safe doing these
yeah so we can go through some of the
obvious things toxicity profile seems to
be very good especially with a compound
like psilocybin magic mushrooms massive
therapeutic index which is the dose that
you would typically take or you might
take therapeutically relative to a dose
that's going to cause your arm or kill
you massive window there right you know
so it's not like a little bit extra is
gonna really cannae whereas there are
many medicines where it's a much tighter
therapeutic licensed medicines much
tighter therapeutic index and legal
drugs like alcohol you know very small
therapy well there's no therapy yeah and
then we can look at yeah mortality risk
they don't you know there's there's no
risk to your physiology where this disk
drugs gonna kill you
at least with a compound like psilocybin
then we can look at addiction potential
negligible addiction potential animals
don't self administer psychedelics they
seem if anything to be fundamentally
aversive and humans only really go there
where they can make mistakes and try and
take them for recreation for fun but
then they get a rude awakening and they
realize that it's true these aren't
party drugs and they shouldn't have
taken LSD at the party yeah yeah so then
more drugs are sort of self-exploration
when taken in the right way and then
people you know often do those
explorations quite sparingly they might
do it a couple of times a year if they
consider themselves a psychedelic user I
mean my impression is that there's
really no standard across which alcohol
should be ready of it readily available
but LSD should be banned I mean there's
really no danger that you get from LSD
that you wouldn't also get it it's like
a hey food danger I think that's it okay
yeah what's what kind of behavioral
thing well if you're you know if you're
on a high dose of LSD or psilocybin and
confused and things are distorted and
all this powerful emotional material is
coming up you probably shouldn't be
wandering around in an urban center
where there's traffic and such like
or maybe in a position of responsibility
for other people yeah a children or
something yeah yeah let's say there are
some risks there and there's also the
psychological vulnerability which should
be considered a risk and for that reason
it's so strongly emphasized in it and
it's so important that it is that the
psychedelic be taken in the right kind
of context and that involves not just
the context for the immediate experience
but also ahead of time that you come
into the experience with some intention
and preparation and forethought and also
some planning for the aftercare as well
for landing and you know and so if those
things are covered then all of a sudden
one could make quite a rational case for
I think opening up access to safe use of
psychedelics within certain centers for
example when you bring patients in do
you give them some sort of psychological
test to make sure they're in a good
place
to do this kind of experiment yeah we do
I mean we do careful screening of course
if they're patients they're often not in
a good place
I shouldn't say patients but volunteers
for the experiment yeah yeah yeah if
they are in a period of psychological
distress and if it's a healthy volunteer
study they would be excluded because it
starts to blur the yeah and the lines
between what's a healthy volunteers
study and a patients that sure you know
one could question that that distinction
anyway but if you're if your question is
how to cite assert how does a certain
psychedelic work in the brain you
probably don't want to blur that with
some kind of therapeutic study yeah okay
and you mentioned Aldous Huxley before
he famously took was it was it LSD as he
was dying he was dying of cancer it was
very very painful he asked to be
administered LSD and apparently it made
his passing much gentler and more
pleasant is that one of the future
therapeutic uses end-of-life care that
we might have been
yeah and so my you and Johns Hopkins
have done some really important work
there Charlie Grove at UCLA and Peter
gasser in Switzerland say there's quite
a few studies and probably most of the
recent clinical trials and actually the
best designed clinical trials have been
these studies in end-of-life to stress
with double-blind randomized control
trials you know the gold standard for
clinical trials in terms of scientific
rigor those designs and yeah they're the
results have been very compelling so
rapid and enduring improvements in the
main mental health outcomes which have
been depressive and anxiety symptoms so
very quick and lasting reductions in
those and so put a more of a human spin
on it you know people report feeling
much more at ease with the inevitable
their inevitable passing and they view
death their death perhaps even death
more generally as something not to be so
frightened of I presume there are some
there's a sort of moralistic attitude in
some people that that would be bad that
you should be resisting death no matter
what and therefore you should face it as
naturally as possible but I'm very much
in the camp that it is something that
should try to come to terms with all
right come yeah well it's inevitable and
that's their syllabus yeah there's some
grace to dying well and some humility
but sure you know your rage rage against
the dying that kind of thing but I mean
who's saying that often is it the loved
one he doesn't want you to pass but
maybe there's true compassion in saying
I want you to pass peacefully and yeah
very very human work in that space and
and used universe
relevant as well well you mentioned this
idea of taking psychedelics in a
controlled environment you know a few
times a year or whatever what do you
what do you foresee as the long-term
good balance about how this stuff is
used so you know you shouldn't take LSD
before you go to a party that that seems
to be something that you're saying but
what do you think is that is the correct
you know social role for these kinds of
things yeah if you were the boss of the
world and could set all the rules there
are some red flags yeah don't take them
at a party be mindful about the dosage
that you take don't take them for escape
that's a really important one I think it
is an important one anyway that's worth
emphasizing it's still you right yeah
you're still facing yourself you are and
and everything underneath you know the
sort of ego self right maybe you're
facing yourself more clearly yeah yeah
and that can be really whether we're the
terror count by opening yes yeah and so
for me I think the roll out would be
these centers where there is regulation
I wouldn't advocate for so the
decriminalization initiatives that are
going on at the moment are interesting
and you can make the argument that
people shouldn't be you know punished or
even incarcerated for exploring their
own consciousness and such like and
perhaps even doing therapeutic work that
could turn their lives around in a
healthy way perhaps make them better
citizens you know so sure you could
argue that but is decriminalization
really the right way for this to roll
out I think initiatives that are
thinking more carefully about the
rollout of psychedelic therapy whether
that be the plant medicines themselves
or the product following the classic
regulatory route obviously well
obviously in my view they they're you
know much more thoughtful and
much healthier way that this can roll
out and there the vision the shared
vision is of centers that are carefully
managed professionally managed we have
key ingredients like careful screening
of people coming in for vulnerabilities
to identify those red flags you know
someone's on the cusp of a psychotic
break perhaps they shouldn't be taking a
big dose of psilocybin which could tip
the balance in a negative way and yet
have mental health professionals there
and to take care of the preparation and
the supervision during the experience
that people are in a very safe container
with ingredients environments of
ingredients in that space that we think
are important like music and carefully
crafted music and then the aftercare as
well mm-hmm you know and if those things
are in place it's actually my view and I
don't mind saying this these days that's
the access to that model could be very
broad not just people who have you know
fit into whatever diagnostic category
but maybe you know people who are well
as well that could benefit from still
the effect on their psychological
well-being how it might help keep them
well and have other you know subtle
advantages in terms of yeah living well
and feeling connected to other people I
think I mean that's an interesting angle
to go down to imagine that intelligent
use of psychedelics could just be part
of living mentally well like keeping up
your own mental health is that is that
something that makes sense yes it does
it does and there's a huge case to be
made there where the burden of mental
illness is so massive that you can make
a case around prophylaxis or
preventative measures
that can improve things like resilience
the ability to have some flex when times
get really tough help put things in
perspective and again these are
hopefully effects that are not just
while you're on the trip but you know
can win afterwards these are about yeah
afterwards really and and there again
you know tying the psychedelic
experience in with other things that are
healthy like you know healthy living
healthy diet cultivating a healthy
attitude you know healthy literature in
a sense and and practices maybe things
like meditation yoga that's where the
rollout could work best I think it does
sound like something that would be hard
to establish scientifically I mean how
much do we know even if you can do an
fMRI study to see which parts of the
brain are lighting up how much do we
know about the long-term mental health
benefits of being or having these
experiences well we can look at other
studies we can look at population
studies we can do cohort studies where
we track people over an extended period
and we've started doing those so we've
set up what I believe will be an
incredibly valuable resource it's
already valuable but I think the future
is going to be really exciting for it's
called psychedelic survey comm and
through that we try and collect
naturalistic data in a prospective way
so that means that we collect data
before the psychedelic trip and
afterwards as well rather than just
doing the classic survey thing which is
to collect everything in retrospect yes
and there you can't make any inferences
about causality in such light this is
about tracking people and ideally
tracking big numbers so we can get big
data and then you know the great merits
of big data is that you can see trends
that are otherwise quite difficult to
see you know is very much a popular
topic in
and Sansome whichever really at the
moment it's big data so yeah and and
they're you know we're picking up some
obvious red flags at the moment and
different variables that predict
responses but that's the kind of thing
that's needed you know that that high
throughput if we're going to be able to
best mitigate risks and learn how to
optimize delivery of psychedelic
experiences and what are the four if
it's if it's one thing that so ordinary
healthy people we all have neuroses we
all have things we can be better at so
maybe this is part of our mental health
care regime or regimen what are the more
obvious mental health problems that
people have for which psychedelics might
be a part of the cure well again this is
a space where psychedelics where the the
buzz that's surrounding psychedelics now
is warranted I feel because you know for
so long people you know probably
motivated by the drugs industry have
been looking for magic bullets that can
come in and target specific diagnosis
with specific chemical actions and then
you'll be cured yeah and the reality is
it that has no it's not like that and so
with psychedelic therapy sure it's it's
early phase data these are just small
pilot studies really but that's
improving and it's it's you know soon
there's gonna be some really compelling
dates rather but part of the picture is
that there's a lot of different
indications a lot of different disorders
that psychedelics are showing signal for
depression treatment resistant
depression anxiety and of life distress
addictions and different varieties
drinking alcohol tobacco now eating
disorders so always starting a trial
this year Hopkins have already started
we think chronic pain others think
chronic pain to the psychological
aspects of pain we think could be quite
effectively treated with psychedelic
therapy obsessive-compulsive disorder
there's some preliminary data on that
and so you know short of wanting to
sound like I'm selling a panacea it's
necessary to try and explain why this
might be the case that psychedelic
therapy has what we call a trans
diagnostic actually it's not a single
thing yeah not a single indication that
it works for there seems to be a lot I
do want to I forgot to emphasize this
possibility of treating addiction
because of course I think the popular
imagination drugs are addicting but in
fact psychedelics seem to be useful in
curing people of it on from being
addicted to other drugs is that right
yeah that's right yeah so an interesting
paradox there's quite a few things that
should really challenge people and maybe
this is part of the jumping out of a rut
to cognitively yes this is it and and
this brings us to the explanation of why
psychedelic therapy could be trans
diagnostic in action in that a lot of
these disorders involve rats
you know whether they're behavioural
rats in depression especially yeah we've
behavioural ruts addiction is very true
in that sense in that you're there's
like a gravitational pull to the object
of relief you know whatever it is and
withdrawal and all the uncertainty in
turmoil when it's not there you know and
then with the depression Matt Johnson
said you know psychedelic therapy could
be useful for addiction broadly defined
and I quite like that because in a sense
in addiction in that depression the
addiction if you want is the pessimism
becomes so practice so habitual so
heavily weighted the gravitational pull
is so strong that it's like a literal
depression you know pulls you in into
that rut and then it's hard to get out
and if you're out you're vulnerable to
falling back in again you know and so
with psychedelic therapy the therapeutic
mechanism we think is that it's almost
if the landscape if you have a literal
depression like a hole that starts to
flatten yeah yeah the rut flattens and
now the landscapes flatter you can
explore you can move more freely you can
see more you know because they arts
lifted up you can see outside of of the
hull and all the possibilities there
sometimes increasing entropy is useful
yeah absolutely
yeah controlled increase in entropy I
mean that's the lesson that I'm learning
from all this is that you know the
well-functioning brain or mind is kind
of all about the balance right between a
little bit of organization a little bit
of freedom a little bit of randomness
and and sometimes that balance gets out
of whack and maybe psychedelics can push
us in one direction when that's
appropriate yeah and it's probably a
universal principle that goes beyond
mental health and and the brain of you
know destruction breeding new
organization but in some way is better
in inverted commas so what is so just to
wrap things up I mean what is the
scientific frontier what is it what you
want to see being done at labs like
yours if you know if you're a pioneer
here what do you want to see being done
around the world what do we need to
understand about the relationship
between psychedelics and the brain for
example yeah there's a couple of things
to say I think a demystification process
where there is this pitfall around
magical thinking and pseudoscience
coming into this space I think it'd be
so healthy actually it will sound
paradoxical but on a spiritual level to
understand what's going on in this
aspect of nature the human brain when
people have these very profound
spiritual experiences under under
psychedelics and that will you know be
hugely
pioneering and progressive for
understanding the brain and the mind and
spiritual experiences and I think that
we'll have a lot of healthy implications
there'll be some resistance to it I
think as a shame but I don't I confident
that the the naturalistic approach will
win out I mean it has historically right
and there was so there will be this
healthy demystification which is good
paradoxically for spiritual practice so
it's lit so I hope that plays out and
another thing is that I hope that the
mainstream that doesn't push back too
hard but embraces this but there's a lot
of areas in which psychedelic therapy
and psychedelic science pushes against
convention so many you know whether it's
depth psychology or well that's you know
hasn't been a dominant force in
psychology and neuroscience for a long
time so that's challenging and then
drugs you know they're not everyone's
cup of tea so we have to work around the
fact that these are drug assisted
psychotherapies and we put aside our our
biases whether that was by medical
models or psychotherapy models and try
and talk to each other and get on with
this hybrid biopsychosocial model and
what else do we have well as so much
mental health itself you know the stigma
there and then I think there's a lot of
conventions in in mainstream science and
psychiatry and medicine that could be
challenged with psychedelic therapy like
the way that you do a traditional
clinical trial where you pick out a
specific indication you constrain
everything around these inclusion
exclusion criteria and then because
usually of financial reasons you run a
very small trial
that throws up you know limited data set
in terms of its richness whereas if you
could set up a trial that perhaps looks
at a range of different indications or a
very broad population let's say you know
health ease all the way up to depressed
with all the neuroticism in between and
yes the same intervention but maybe you
can allow some adaptability in the
parameters maybe the dose the dosage and
the dosing sessions and maybe also the
integration care and the therapeutic
models could be tweaked and played with
so that that's consistent with what's
called an adaptive trial and also the
idea of a broad population is consistent
with what's called a basket or basket
trial where you're putting a lot of
different things in the same basket with
the same intervention okay so that kind
of things done in oncology where you
would have a number of different cancers
with the same intervention why not
psychiatry you know one of the reasons
why not probably is it slightly flies in
the face or it seems to of this fashion
around precision medicine okay people
will say where's the precision there but
I think there's there's a lot to be said
for the exploration and the benefits
that can come from that liberal
explorative approach to the science of
this stage particularly as it's quite
young science it's it's somehow like 50
years a missed opportunity because you
know it's been difficult to do this
research yeah yeah it is and say there's
a huge amount to be done and I think you
know the progress will benefit if we
don't constrain things too too heavily
but it sounds like you're optimistic
that things are changing and we're going
to start using this stuff more
intelligent yeah very optimistic of
course you know you can be jackknifed
when when you're looking in one
direction with optimism and then you
know something comes along and really
pushes back and that's yet to happen and
we haven't seen what its gonna look like
will happen but I I mean what gives me
confidence is the conviction in the in
in the model and the value of the tool
all right Robin Carhartt Harris thanks
so much being on podcast thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]